I've become very very interested
in the idea
of playing in games that have no finish lines.
Some games have finish lines,
baseball, football.
Getting a part is a finish line.
You audition,
there's a beginning, middle and end.
There's rehearsal and practice.
There's showing up for the audition
and you either win or you lose,
and then it's over.
That is finite.
But one's career is infinite.
There's no end.
It's like our lives are finite
but life is infinite.
People come and
people go but life continues.
Theater.
Actors come and actors go
but theater continues.
It's infinite.
You don't win theater.
You win a part.
But what happens once you get the part?
The finite game is over.
Now you enter the infinite game,
you have to be able to convert.
And the reason this is important,
and I've seen this unfortunately so many times,
from a young age
all you wanted to do was get to Broadway.
And then you get to Broadway,
and then what?
You've devoted your entire life to one finite goal
and when you get there,
the immediate response is depression
because I spent 15 years of my life
for this one thing
and I got it
and now I don't know what to do next.
Like what do,
get to Broadway again?!
It doesn't have the same ambition.
It doesn't have the same passion,
that you've devoted,
you're from Fargo, North Dakota
and that's all you wanted to do is
get out of Fargo and make it to Broadway
and you made it.
It doesn't have the same kind of passion.
and this is because these are
finite goals.
There's a lot of studies that have been done with
athletes who have finite goals.
To become the greatest X in the world.
So Andre Agassi was one of these athletes.
He wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived.
So guess what?
Everyone in his life
he would view them through,
how do you help me get to that?
Everything was
how does this help me get to that?
Everything was a transaction,
how do you help me move to there,
and then you know what happens?
He achieved it,
he became the greatest tennis player in the world
and you know what happened immediately after?
Depression.
Michael Phelps set out to become the most medaled Olympian in history
Do you know what?
He achieved it.
You know what happened immediately after?
Depression.
They spend their whole life working for
one goal.
Though most will never get it,
the few that do,
don't know what to do next
because their goals were finite.
Their goals were finite.
And so there are finite components to your career
but your career should be infinite.
So yes, of course you have to win
the finite game.
You have to get the part.
But immediately when you get the part
now you convert to infinite.